I want to talk today about the scam of
modern conservatism and how the right is
manipulating and exploiting people with
an ideology that exists only in theory
and in reality is completely different
from that which it claims to be let me
explain modern conservatism is a
political ideology that claims to be
about limited government
individual liberty and responsibility
Traditional Values Freedom not
regulating businesses on and on and on
and there's two parts of this the first
part is that in theory all of that
sounds really appealing it's sort of
like hey doesn't paying no taxes sound
appealing in some general sense I mean
yeah I'd love to keep every dollar that
I gross and not pay any taxes in some
general sense that sounds pretty good it
sounds appealing in certain contexts the
ideas espoused by conservatism
sound uh beneficial but in practice
modern conservatism has become a scam
that is used to manipulate and exploit
people and its values are just as
quickly abandoned by those espousing
them once they are no longer convenient
or productive or helping their cause
let's talk about some examples one way
that modern conservatism is being used
to manipulate the public is through
propaganda and misinformation
conservative media outlets and
politicians will often spread misleading
information
based on their supposed principles in
order to win elections at the end of the
day all they care about is winning
elections and this includes conspiracy
theories when it's convenient
cherry picking data using completely
loaded language to evoke an emotional
response we are pro-life
wow everybody else must be against life
that sounds pretty bad we're for tax
relief
wow taxes must just simply be oppressive
taxes must be like slavery which is
quite literally what some Libertarians
say and by using this language and
manipulating The public's understanding
of the facts conservatives shape public
opinion and influence policy decisions
and voters in their favor in ways that
are completely misleading and don't
actually benefit the people that end up
voting for them and that's a big part of
the scam and we're going to get back to
that
another way that the public is exploited
by the scam of conservatism is through
dog whistle politics so this is when
they use coded language that certain
groups of people understand to have a
specific meaning like for example when
they say family values
I mean that sounds pretty good right
like families are good and values that
support families that all sounds good
but it's a signal to conservative voters
you're supposed to be opposed to
same-sex marriage you're supposed to be
opposed to abortion more recently you're
supposed to be opposed to even
fundamental just basic trans rights they
don't say it outright and this allows
the right-wing politicians to appeal to
certain groups of Voters without
alienating others it allows them to
avoid accountability and it allows
something that Donald Trump actually did
very well which is you kind of take
every position on issues and even if you
don't overtly do it you leave enough
vagaries that anybody could sort of
stumble across some version of a
position that they agree with you or at
least don't overtly disagree modern
conservatism also exploits the public
through policy and this is maybe the
most important thing
right wing conservative whatever word
you want to use for it policy
disproportionately benefits the wealthy
the powerful and those with what we
might call like standard or agent
identities in American society and
conservatives will argue lower taxes are
good for everybody increases economic
growth increases Prosperity Rising tide
lifts all boats they'll say it with
regulation reducing regulation is good
for everybody economic growth prosperity
it's great the truth is it's a scam
those very policies they they do
particularly in the short term increase
profits for corporations in the wealthy
but they externalize the burden of the
pollution that is created or the low
wages that are paid which then we all
have our taxes go to social welfare
programs to support people who rightly
need those programs because the
corporations are paying low wages they
claim it's good for everybody their
economic policy is good for everybody
but it leads to cuts and social services
or increased spending on Social Services
higher health care costs lower wages for
workers we all pay for it we are getting
scammed by it
so modern conservatism is a scam that by
scamming the public and exploiting the
public through all of the things I
mentioned
disproportionately benefits the elites
they love to say Democrats are all about
this elitist cabal that's that's all
they care about it's actually
conservatism that is doing that a couple
modern examples we can look at how
right-wingers sought to undermine the
legitimate legitimacy of the 2020
presidential election there was no
evidence of widespread voter fraud that
impacted the results they scammed their
supporters they raised money Trump did
claiming we're going to use the money to
flip the election he kept the money used
it to pay off campaign debt total and
complete scam we've seen these
conspiracies promoted by conservative
media outlets and by politicians by
Trump himself and that is the
prototypical example of how conservatism
is used to make the public think a
certain thing
and then get them to take an action
either going to the Capitol donating
money whatever the case may be uh we
have also seen by the way this very same
rhetoric used in order to get the public
to support ideas that are seemingly
completely antithetical to the values of
the right for example
free speech for all including for
businesses until we no longer like the
speech and moderation rules that are
being applied on Twitter or Facebook or
whatever and all of a sudden Freedom
Liberty and Low regulation goes out the
window and it's we must Force Facebook
to publish our coveted disinformation we
must Force Twitter to publish the
pictures of Hunter Biden's genitalia
they abandoned those principles right
away and the voters at the end of the
day are just getting scammed they don't
know up down left right they don't know
what's going on last thing on this when
you
Wonder
what is the end game with any of these
supposedly conservative policy ideas
whether it's the immigration reform
ideas they have taxation whatever the
case may be understand that the end goal
is to reinforce and perpetuate
the rich and corporations maintaining
power and profitability that is the big
scam that they claim their entire
movement is a set of policies that helps
everyone
and it doesn't and we've talked before
about how that that is that is not
completely missing from the Democratic
party but the degree to which it exists
in the modern right-wing movement is
completely stunning it is a scam last
week uh we spoke about what it is about
people who are victimized by scams that
keeps them being victimized and part of
it is is the cult aspect and part of it
is psychological factors we looked at
the people being scammed now we've
looked at what the scam is
and it would be great if people would
figure this out and stop falling for it
but it actually is a party that depends
on people continuing to fall for it